uh the first thing is this is not a
basic tdd talk and I won't explain how
to do tdd right so I would expect you to
understand at least that tdd is a
process by which we write test before we
write code and there is a cycle of red
green and refactor where we write a
failing test we then get that test to
pass and then we do a new refactoring to
improve the quality of our code right
you need to know kind of that much it
doesn't matter if you're practicing tddd
currently um it just matters that you
understand kind of what tdd is about and
how gener gets
presented uh the other thing about this
talk is I will definitely be having a um
I will be criticizing what is often seen
as the prevailing approach to test
driven development right I'll be
criticizing a kind of approach based on
unit test mocks everything else and even
uh gkin based syntax style acceptance
tests if you are deeply wedded to those
and no one is ever going to persuade you
that that is the wrong way of doing
something you may want to find somebody
else to talk to because that is what I'm
going to try and do today and if that's
that's something you're going to go I
don't want to hear any of that right no
point in you're being here right if you
have an open mind we'll try and explain
different ways of doing things right and
if you've tried tdd and you have bounced
off it
this may help you understand why and may
help you understand a way that may work
for you better right hopefully you will
be able to write less uh simpler better
tests uh this is not a code based talk
as well right this is a theory based
talk it explains the theory of how you
do tdd correctly so if you want
something demo heavy that isn't this
talk either all right so anyone who
wants to run away I am really happy that
you go and find the talk that will work
for you rather than sort of s through my
talk and being disappointed because it
didn't give you what you wanted right
it's your time I don't want to waste
it all
right most of this is dull I tend to
call out the point at the bottom there
is often in lecture style relationships
a bit of a impression that I am somehow
you know the expert and you are not um
we're all just software Engineers I just
got lucky enough early on in my career
to um have to go and talk at the user
group was running we all had to share
talking because there were no experts
that we could draw on in the early days
of net so I got past the confidence
issue of standing up and talking to you
all but I'm no smarter than any of you
right and you should you could do this
you just need to get audiences like user
groups and stuff locally where you can
build up the confidence to talk in front
of
people um doet developers in the
room I work on an open source uh project
for messaging called brighter and doing
cqrs we are very friendly towards W open
source contribution other open source
and Commercial open source messaging
Frameworks do exist we not better or
worse but give us a
try right what's the agenda there's not
really an agenda actually clean
architecture is not on there anymore I
don't think um we're just going to talk
about the fallaces of tdd and the
principles
right
okay the first and perhaps the most
significant fallacy of test driven
development is the developers right unit
test
s nothing could be further from the
truth tdd has nothing zero to do with
unit
tests so if I look on Wikipedia I can
get a reasonable definition of unit
testing right Wikipedia says to isolate
issues that may arise each test case
should be tested
independently substitutes such as method
stubs mock objects fakes and test
harnesses
can be used to assist testing a module
in isolation what does that mean right
so once upon a time when we talked about
how we were going to automate testing we
tested modules modules are neously
defined right it could be a class could
be much bigger and the idea was that
module was treated as a black box and
your test probed the module from the
outside and you wanted to make sure that
any failures your testing gave you were
inside the box so any dependencies that
box have you would replace with a fake
or a substitute that's classical
automated
testing
okay the
problem is trying to apply this as a
paradigm to test driven development so
what happened was when test driven
development
emerged some people who were familiar
with automated
testing assumed and began to teach other
people tdd on the basis that it was just
automated testing and it's
not so there are some problems with that
right the first problem is there's a lot
of focus on isolation in tdd right the
idea is that for defect
localization I need to understand that
all the errors are in this component not
one of its collaborators therefore I
must use substitutes that I understand
for all of its collaborators
test doubles are a term we tend to use
to describe these things the IDE is of
like a stunt double right something that
stands in for the actor who we can't
expose to danger and so that what
happens in a lot of people who are
influenced by unit testing is they take
a class because they decide that's the
equivalent of a module from automated
software engineer testing and they
replace all of its dependencies with
substitutes and eventually what this led
to was a paradigm of thought in test
driven development sometimes called
need- driven development those of you
who have read the book growing
objectoriented software with tests this
book espouses particularly this
philosophy of what's called need- driven
development it's a variation on the test
driven development process where code is
written from the outside in so in other
words you start effectively at the
outside with the kind of function or
method that you're getting under test
and all dependent upon code is replaced
by mock objects that verify the expected
indirect outputs of the code being
written so in other words if I have any
kind of
collaborator then I'm going to replace
it with a substitute and I'm going to
verify in my test the calls I make to
that
substitute one of the issues here is
that generally this involves upfront
design
I have to either understand perhaps I
did cic cards perhaps I had a
whiteboard why how I'm
partitioning my domain space into
objects because I have to know well this
responsibility isn't the thing under
test it's the responsibility of
something else which I will effectively
replace with a mock or a stop so I'm
doing upfront design I'm not letting the
tests inform my
design
okay another alternative to this which
is the one that growing object turn to
with software test tends to basically um
uh offer is that as you begin to do your
implementation in response to test you
realize oh this next bit probably needs
to be another another class the
responsibility needs to be handed off so
at that point I will then I'm doing
Discovery so I will now write my test
for that mock right
there's an overall problem with this
right that's basically began to hamper a
lot of our
development and that is that
essentially we now in our test
understand the implementation
details of the method or class that we
are going to basically test we must
understand its details because we have
to understand the interaction it has
with collaborators in order to get its
job
done we also tend to get forced into a
world where most those collaborators are
public things that we can otherwise test
they're not internal or private they are
not
hidden as long ago as 2007 which makes
me feel really
old I wrote this because the tdd
community understood at the time that
people were going in the wrong direction
and we tried shouting a lot but this
automated software engineering mirroring
kind of like Paradigm had really took
taken over and back in then I said when
I look around now I see a lot of people
using mocks to replace all of their
dependencies my concern is they will
begin to hit the fragile test issues
that mocks present Gerard ma mazos
identifies the issues we hear as two
specific smells over specified software
and behavior
sensitivity so typically what happens is
in a strugly type language like Java or
C you say oh my collaborat
I need to be able to substitute those I
will create an interface for them so
rather than neing anything up in the
Constructor of my class if I want to
basically use components so I can
effectively compose behaviors rather
than using inheritance I have to inject
to my dependencies previously we tended
to use dependency injection for things
like strategy pan or effectively to
support layering where effectively I
couldn't know basically about the
concrete class and a lad that was above
me for example but suddenly we were
using interfaces to inject all of our
dependencies and the result of that was
we couldn't any even more use any kind
of like what we call Poor Man's di where
composition was from the root and
everything just well I can just new up
my dependencies Etc and pass into some
config suddenly we had these really long
chains of interfaces in our
Constructors which meant we needed to
all start using ioc Frameworks to build
our code
bases right if you ever wondered
hang on a minute my class seems to be
this mess of dependencies I can't
actually create anything without ioc
Frameworks is this the right thing and
the answer is probably no we've kind of
Trapped ourselves
right what do you mean by Behavior
sensitivity we
mean the problem is that essentially we
should be able to change the
implementation details of our code
without breaking
tests right tests are intended to focus
on the
contract but actually our tests are
focused on the implementation details
and generally what you see you see this
behavior when as you try and change
something and then you go ah I got to
fix the 300 broken tests because I
changed the way we co that interface on
that other class right that shouldn't
happen you're changing an implementation
detail that shouldn't break your
tests and that also leads to this
problem where people stop refactoring
or they try and work around basically
avoiding making changes because it's
kind of like yeah I can't do that so
many tests will break that would take us
days to fix let's do something else but
tests were supposed to make our code
more Supple they're supposed to enable
refactoring why are they preventing us
from
refactoring okay so the principle you
need to understand a principle that's
been around since the beginning of tdd
is that developers write developer tests
sometimes called programmer tests not
unit
tests it's worth noting so when Kent
writes tdd by example Kent is not the
originator of tdd and he would admit to
that I think um Kent is documenting a
practice that he and others in various
software communities have been using for
some time and if you go and read tdd by
example it has information on marks
exceptions from development lots of
ideas that people think came much later
they already knew about they already
understood and it's discussed right so
he's documenting practice that people
are using for a wider
audience and Kent says I call the unit
tests but they don't match the accepted
definition of unit tests very well this
is the only reference to unit tests in
the entire book you can go and search it
that's the only time it's mentioned what
it means is in casual conversation we
occasionally say unit tests when he
built junit he referred to them as unit
test it's one of these kind of like you
know billion dollar mistakes right a bit
like using the word micro with micr
Services right people started get to go
off on a tangent of completely the wrong
set of ideas and they brought in units
from automated software
engineering
okay all
right so we can understand what we
should be doing better if we look at
refactoring so this is Martin Fowler's
definition of refactoring a change made
to the internal structure of software to
make it easier to understand and cheap
to modify without changing its
observable
Behavior so refactoring is very clear
right I've got some observable Behavior
things that other people depend upon
that my class effectively does right if
I want to change how it does it a more
efficient algorithm better structure
effectively breaking it into small
classes I should be able to do
that
right Guided by my tests to ensure that
effectively I don't break anything thing
so red green refractor is the tdd cycle
refractor is the last step often you see
people practicing tdd going yeah I mean
we just do a lot of red and green we
never really refactor right that's a
smell it's a smell that effectively
what's happened is you've got a design
up front you are now trying to get under
test because in the green phase what you
should be doing is anything you can to
find the algorithm that you need to pass
the
test so you can go and copy code from
stack Overflow copy Pastor it that's
absolutely fine in the green phase you
can go and ask chat gbt to tell you how
you should write that code and cut and
paste it in that's absolutely fine in
the green phase you will make the code
good once it passes the test because now
you know exactly the code you need to
pass the test and you can then refactor
to write high quality code right you can
improve on what chat GPT gave you
right so your code is exposing a
contract and what we want you to do is
test that contract test I can Implement
that contract and then have tests which
say I continue to meet that
contract but you should be able to
change how you implement that contract
without breaking any of your tests and
the problem with mocks is that every
time you trying to change the
implementation details you will keep
breaking your
tests km Beck said basically I think
somewhere in uh mid teens basically if a
program's behavior is stable from an
observer's perspective no tests should
change in other words when I'm
refactoring and I change the
contract change the implementation
rather than the contract then I
shouldn't change any tests right so it's
a contract first approach to testing in
tdd right behavior is the cont contract
the API that you are exposing in other
words the public methods of a class
right okay and again Kent said even more
recently because this whole thing you
know we we we never seem to win against
the the bad ideas of automated software
engineering test should be coupled to
the behavior of code and decoupled from
the structure of code seeing tests that
fail on both counts in other words the
tests Express the contract that you want
to see from that particular class right
not how you've chosen to implement
that uh there's a big uh kind of Meetup
with uh dhh greater ran rails on for
toer of our industry um Kent Beck also
by Martin Fowler because um dhh in his
usual way to obtain clicks had
effectively said
um I'm done with tdd uh and I feel good
about saying that it's basically not
done me any good I end up with these
test Suites that make changing my code
hard and everything else right and the
thing is I think to be to be fair what
he' done is fallen into the very much
the automated software engineering unit
test based approach effectively to
testing and and Kent said in that
interview that the dialogue that Martin
basically created between the two of
them my personal style is I just don't
go very far down the mock path your test
is completely coupled to the
implementation of the interface of
course you can't change anything without
breaking the
tests right so we don't do this kind of
mock driven
testing
right because that means effectively we
are observing the thing under test by
indirect outputs not by simply saying
something on the lines of there is State
before there is state after and I've
somehow transformed it right
preconditions and post conditions that's
really what you want to focus on right
preconditions and post conditions what
does the world look like before I did
this exercise this Behavior what does
the world look like
now
okay
so this is the definition effectively of
a unit test right failure of a unit test
shall implicate one and one only unit a
method class module or package so unit
tests do defect localization via
substitution okay this is the definition
of a programmer or developer test that
you use in test driven
development failure of a program or
developer test under test driven
development implicates only the most
recent
edit so the way you do defect
localization is I have a sweet of green
tests I make a small change to my
code if the if any tests now go red
which used to be
green the defect is localized to them to
the code I just wrote
this is the reason in tdd we recommend
that you take small
jumps what's the smallest increment of
behavior that you could now get under
test because that localizes the defect
so Kent has a thing about driving in
Gears which I think must confuse
Americans because I'm pretty sure they
drive automatic rather than stick shift
but what he's talking about is this idea
that the higher the gear you in the more
more code you write at any one time the
more confident you have to be about what
you're doing the more you have to feel
I've done this a thousand times it's
okay I can write 80 lines of code
without there being too many defects I'm
good the less comfortable you feel the
smaller the amount of code the narrower
the test you need to write in order to
essentially um understand where the
defects are so I typically get questions
about oh when you talk about tdd in this
in this way could I do it by tdd my HTTP
API and the answer is sure you could if
that works for you but you're taking a
big jump so defect localization now is
right across that span of your you know
your your web controller um the
marshalling basically of stuff into
format Etc all the way down to your
Handler if that's actually quite simple
maybe you're comfortable driving at the
level where effectively you make those
big jumps and you you're okay with
figuring out where defects are in that
right if not you want to go a bit lower
right so maybe you want to use a ports
and adapter's architecture and test at
the port or maybe it's a really complex
algorithm when you want to test lower
down at the individual class but it's
kind of up to you to make a choice tdd
doesn't really have a rule other than
driving a gear you feel comfortable with
that you can localize the defect in the
amount of code you've just
committed and if you find yourself
hitting the debugger a lot you're making
too big a
jump right real the hard hardcore tdd
folks from back in the early two late
'90s early 2000s used to say oh if
you've added a whole if you added sort
of a whole L of lines of code and then
you break stuff just in test break
delete that code and try again right and
it's pretty hardcore I'm okay I'd be
like you can use a debugger right but
the reason they had that rule was to try
and persuade people not to write 200
lines of code with each test because
you'd have to lose 200 lines of code so
that's the reason for the ru is trying
to basically say to people don't jump
too
far
okay um but a full definition of test
development is so the C2 Wiki which is
kind of slowly fading in the way that
you know the our history on the Internet
is slowly getting killed which is never
a great thing says test driven
development produces developer tests the
failure of a test case implicates only
the developer most recent edit this
implies that Developers don't need to
use mock objects to split their code up
into testable units and it implies a
developer may always avoid debugging by
reverting that last edit
right so I tend to basically in casual
conversation where I can try and use
program developer test even I will
occasionally use the word unit right
because it's become so
prevalent um tdd is a process of
discovery right in other words you are
seeking to effectively not do huge
amounts of design up front take your
contract and then effectively slowly
explore the implementation that you
need and so you don't use mock objects
to the same extent you would in this
classical model you don't need to
isolate the thing under test there are
some cases Mo objects will take talk
about them in a minute okay um and that
means essentially you can do stuff like
use new to create a class in your con a
component in your Constructor rather
than injector it's amazingly liberating
when you can say hey I don't actually
need to use di for everything
right there is one use case where
effectively we may want to think about
using substitutes so the confusion
around unit test actually really stems
most of all from this statement by Kent
how should the running of tests affect
one another not at all so when he was
using unit his thing was your test
should be able to run in parallel tests
need to be fast because we don't want to
break your flow and force you out of
basically the work you're doing in
incrementally working towards solving a
requirement by making you go and do a
whole making you go I'll go and make
coffee while my tests run right we don't
want that we want test to be I press a
button within 30 seconds okay that's all
green I can keep moving right whereas if
he's kind of like I run my tests any
want Fanci a coffee
then that's a disaster because I break
my flow the model gets torn down I have
to St step things up again so Kent's
thing was isolation of tests from each
other and that's why he inadvertently
used the word unit and that's what
caused all the problems a little bit
right tests are isolated from each other
so that they can run in parel which
keeps them fast the most common problem
that causes tests not be able to run
together is what we call shared fixture
in other words that means something
where a itively two tests will change
the same set of state so for example you
have a table in a database and one thing
says I'm going to count the number of
rows after I do this operation and
another test says oh I'm going to add
some rows and if you run those two
they're going to come run in a random
order and essentially if the one that
adds the other rows runs basically at
the wrong moment in time it could affect
the result of the other and you get this
erratic test that fails occasionally
right some some of you may seen that
right or static um uh and you know
languages like C we use a static
variable so effectively you have Global
State and you're basically impacting
Global state in your test so where you
have a shared fixture you need to avoid
the problem with the shared fixture one
way to do that is to use basically a
test up like a mock or a fake it isn't
the only way right you may be able to
actually make sure that you protect that
you may be able to run those some of
those tests sequentially because you
don't have too many of them but one way
to do that so IO is most commonly the
problem we experience for shared
fixtures and so quite it's quite common
to decide I will replace this thing
that's doing IO like talking to a
database with a shared with a with a
mock in order to avoid the shared
fixture problem
okay the other reason we may want to use
a mock for Io is just speed right if
this thing is slow fragile because it
involves some kind of network connection
or talks to resources that might not be
available in order to avoid the problem
of test break it's fragile or test take
a long time again it's another reason to
replace something with a mock so tdd by
example kect talks all about mocks but
that's the reason they want to use them
right to to allow your tests to run fast
and run independently not to isolate the
thing under
test
okay so let's dig a bit deeper the next
thing I tend to see is that people get T
okay before you write any method
write a test for that method right so
typically the rule people have is the
trigger for a new test is writing a new
function even Wikipedia bless its heart
says write a test it defines a function
or impr improvements of a function okay
Wikipedia is very
wrong okay it seems to make sense right
we talked about basically saying tests
well you have preconditions how does the
world look before I run my test and I
have post conditions how does the the
world look after I Pally run my function
seems to make sense that would be a good
interception point right implementation
is just how do I Implement that
function there are some
problems the function basically is the
system under test is basically what
we're saying right so we want to conf
testing them then becomes confirming
that functions work so you have a
function that says for example um uh you
know calculate Fu right and you say okay
here are my parameters maybe I'll do a
parameterized test and I say effective
I'm going to run calculate Fu and here's
the results I expect when I run
calculate
F
okay um one of the questions that then
comes up is oh uh private methods you
occasionally see this uh how do I get
those under test and you see people go C
sh people go oh use internal visible
internals visible to so you can reach in
and get that one and the answer is never
test your private methods right they're
an implementation
detail anything that is internal or
private to your module never test it you
only test the public interface that
other people depend
upon
right because those are implementation
details you're at liberty to change them
that's the whole reason you put them
made them basically internal to your
module or uh private is so you could
just change them when you felt like it
right you only to test the things that
other people depend upon that's where
behavior is expressed
okay well that look all right that
doesn't really yeah we'll come back to
that um often when you return to your
test it's difficult to understand the
intent the trouble with basically the
kind of get Fu thing is it has a whole
lot of parameterized numbers and assert
values right and sometimes it breaks and
I go okay so has it broken when I give
get Fu 20 and 30 because I've I've
broken the implementation of G Fu or is
the change the customer wanted mean that
20 and 30 don't have that result anymore
it's probably not clear from the test
it's just give get food 20 and 30 check
that value equals whatever
right one of the promises we were made
about tdd that people sometimes Mock and
laugh about on the internet because
people on the on Twitter are experts in
things right and one of those things
they go ah yeah there was this idea we
didn't need documentation any anymore
because our test would be an executable
specification which would enable us to
understand how to use the code haaha
have you ever tried re seeing any tests
isn't that awful right and the answer is
the way you write tests absolutely I can
I can believe that but genuine tdd
doesn't have that problem we actually
get genuine executable specifications
for our code that's B one a
second okay so somewhat alarmingly
perhaps for people who like to go and
use spec flow and tools like that tdd as
in programmer and developer tests by
origin say the trigger for a new test is
a new
behavior that is the level tdd has
always been
at so K back tdd by example this is a
typical this is one of the things that
Kent by example is showing you how to
build tddd we need to be able to add
amounts in two different currencies and
convert the result given a set of
exchange rates not we need to test the
um uh add amounts method and see that
basically when we add 20 and 30 together
we will get 50 or whatever Right add
amounts convert result given a set of
exchange
rates given a set of exchange rates when
we add amounts in two different
currencies then we convert the
result we can rewrite that as what's
called GWT or given when then test which
basically is an observation from uh down
North
basically given a set of exchange rates
when I add two amounts in different
currencies together then I get a result
in the first currency that is how tdd
works and always has done since tdd by
example not here is my method I want to
add one given the state of the world
before the test when I exercise the
behavior under test tdd works against
behaviors right then we expect the the
following changes
the same thing so as a four-fold test
model by Jared mazaris setup exercise
verify tear down same thing as actor
range aert from Bill wake right given a
set basically of given the world before
a test when I exercise a behavior not a
method a behavior which might include
calls to more than one
method then we expect the following
changes right and it's this because Dan
North created the term Behavior driven
development very early on in the public
life of tdd right early in the ughs Dan
said I found the shift from thinking and
Testa thinking of behavior so profound
that I started to refer to tdd as bdd or
behavior driven development note there
is no difference at this point in time
between what tdd and bdd are he simply
renames tdd as bdd for his consultancy
clients because he finds they are
confused by the word test they start
thinking about automated software
engineering and unit tests so he says
let's just call it Behavior driven
development so you understand it's about
testing behaviors not
units
okay um so this was an really important
observation because it said we're all
about the contracts we're all about the
behaviors that's what tdd does right now
I I would caution you that bdd has since
become its own thing and I'm pretty down
on bdd too to so for those of you
thinking yay I like bdd in about to tell
me that's great no sorry um but uh the
original blog post that Dan gave and the
original kind of naming strategy where
he said it's Behavior driven development
is good some of the things bdd has
become are bad I'll explain why when we
talk about acceptance testing in a
minute all
right uh so B all these slides by the
way they're in my GitHub you can just go
to uh GitHub for Ian Cooper and
presentations uh Kemp seven years after
I think it's called or something because
when I wrote this it was seven years
after in the pandemic basically uh talk
I gave in 2014 so you can find this talk
in there um so those of you want the
slides particularly to look at the
little detail bits all there for you so
you can reference it later the idea
behind some of the blue text is so you
can reference the material later with
your colleagues who are crying when you
tell them that what Ian said right
okay the next test you write in tdd is
just the most the obvious step that you
can make towards implementing a
requirement given by a use case or a
user story right however you basically
decide to take in your requirements use
cases user storage whatever it is you
use doesn't matter you've got some
criteria from a customer that says well
this is the thing we want right and then
what you need to do is say okay how do I
make the thing we want what are the
behaviors that entails what would be a
nice contract for everyone that really
expressed that so that they could really
understand that's what we're trying to
basically build
right so think about how the quality of
the contract from the point of view of
someone using the methods that you're
writing to implement it make it obvious
how it works right that's the point of
tdd you can in when you write the test
you can really explore for yourself
wonder if that API is obvious does it
make sense is it self-documenting you
can do all that stuff that's what the
test is for exploring the contract not
for adding mocks and
substitutes okay so the next test right
typically one of the problems in
development is is always what do I do
next how do I start right you start by
saying what is the behavior I need to
implement what is the simplest test I
could write what is the smallest bit of
that functionality I could get under
test
right so what is the smallest challenge
the reason the smallest challenge is
because comfort about the number of
lines of code you are adding defect
localization so try and moveing smaller
chunks so you get better defect
localization okay and the user story or
use case tells you what the requirements
are right so one one one or two of you
may be saying oh that's interesting when
I do uh my kind of development I end up
with some unit tests that test all the
little methods of my classes then I have
specflow or cucumber or something and
that tests all the behaviors that the
the actual behaviors wouldn't that be
better in shouldn't I be using that no
I'll talk about that in a minute
okay the other thing that people Miss is
this you do not write new tests if you
introduce methods when refractor to
clean code so what happens typically
what in the best world right when I get
to the green phase I write this method
that's about like a 100 lines long uh
Scrolls over several Pages probably has
lines that are too long and is awful
right frankly awful a chat GPT has
generated at for me and I've just cut
and pasted the goddamn thing in right do
that honestly it's perfectly fine Ian go
and tell your boss Ian said that's fine
you can get chat GPT to tell you the
answer right get how a co-pilot will
look at your test for you and it will
write the answer based on the test the
better you make the test in terms of
behavior the easier chck copilot's going
to find it to do that for you right but
then what you do is say that's really
unmaintainable code and I can't possibly
ship that I'd like to express intent so
I will take this chunk of methods and
refactor it into a refactor into a
method expresses intent right I don't
need a new test refactoring is a safe
operation I don't introduce branches
like if statements and things like that
that code is under test it's the test
that I
wrote at the beginning of this process
when I it's it's covered because
essentially I'm not introducing a new
Branch or path right I'm just saying be
nice if that was a method explain stuff
typically if you have a language that
has access modifiers that may be a
private or internal to the module method
right you're typically not exposing it
to Consumers it's just clearing up how
you implement if I have a 100 lines of
code I might say hm
that looks like at quite a separate
responsibility it's going to be easier
to maintain that by making a new class I
can refactor something into a class
right typical way to do that extract the
method figure out basically what in the
method should be the state that belongs
to the class and should be
hidden create a new class put the method
across and effectively threw a
Constructor set the behavior it depends
upon right I still don't need a new
test right it is covered by the original
t test that expresses the
behavior you should have many less tests
than you do because you are effectively
only testing the observable Behavior
because I might break it into two
classes and you might go Ah that's made
it a bit complicated I prefer to see
they all in line it' be easier to
understand I'm going to in line all that
and that's perfectly valid as a team we
will eventually land on what is the most
maintainable way we should do this right
but you'll be frustrated won't do that
if someone makes a new class and it has
tests be go like well I have to delete
all the tests and right don't do
that refactoring is changed
implementation that changes the Behavior
Uh but implication we must be covered by
the existing tests um including a new
class right so the reason you're not
refactoring quite often is because
you're not understanding refactoring
effectively you shouldn't be breaking
your
implementation all right customers write
acceptance tests cucumber spef plans
okay uh I am sorry
okay so where do these come from
originally they were called functional
tests because each acceptance test Tri
has to test the functionality of a user
Story the idea was acceptance tests are
modeled and possibly even written by a
customer thus customer test nowadays we
don't have XP style customers nowadays
we have product owners or product
managers or whatever your particular
flavor is called at your organization uh
the same thing they're just a proxy for
the customer we began to introduce
proxies because we couldn't get hold of
actual customers right
okay so this idea from XP was originally
you got some on-site customer
representative of the customer right
they were domain expert and they could
answer questions about what the
requirement was right and the idea is
the customer defines the acceptance
criteria haven't we just said that tdd
should be working against acceptance
criteria why do I need this additional
indirection of acceptance test then
isn't what haven't I already got tests
with acceptance
criteria oh okay I
understand they're tests that are
written by the product owner or the
customer they write them not the
developer how many of you have tests
written in Spec flow Fitness something
like that come on be
brave okay keep your hands up if the
customer genuinely goes and writes those
tests right none of you every time I ask
this question I've never had a hand in
the air but that is their point
that is why you that is why those tools
exist for the customer to write the test
directly if you're writing the test as a
developer just use your xunit junit
nunit tool right there's no point in you
having the indirection of taking English
language trying to push it through
something where effectively to become a
real test they're hard to maintain they
break all the time
right so James Shaw was one of the guys
that wrote fit fit was a very early
basically acceptance testing Tool uh it
essentially worked by effectively right
this origin by using HTML tables later
basically use wikis and it allowed
customers to write tests so James has
skin in the game right James actually is
one of the people that wrote one of
these tools and he said there are two
problems customers don't participate
which eliminates the purpose of
acceptance testing and they create a
significant maintenance burden meaning
acceptance testing is not worth the cost
I no longer use a commender I forced
teams to try and do specflow and Fitness
in my in my in my younger years they
hated me and I understand why because I
was being an idiot right someone told me
last night 27s about Peete Dunning
Krueger for men I I can believe it
right so um
uh there's no point in using things like
cucumber style or fit right unless the
customer is actively participating
writing the testt and the part the
problem is they're much harder to
maintain
than your unit test suite and because
they're much harder to maintain you
effectively pay a huge cost but you're
getting no benefit because it's
developers reading the test and they
could have just read it in the xunit
tool Kemp Beck well this is me bet you
uh ATD is paral because implies that tdd
does not deal with acceptance criteria
for user Stories part of the problem
with this whole acceptance test model in
specflow and fitness other places is it
implies well what are unit what are the
other tests for there must be units then
they're the small bits that build up to
how I implement this right so we've kind
of helped
reinforce this broken automated testing
model of how we do tdd its units
integration tests and everything else
rather than developer and programmer
tests by introducing these tools which
means we're asking the question well
what is what the developer tests for
then right or there must be units if we
just said everybody test behavior in TD
we'd realize we didn't need these
tools excuse me
get back again in tdd by example so we
already knew from existing experience
about the practice at the point when
Kent writes the book right an aspect of
tdd is the length of cycle between test
and feedback if the customer writes a
test in 10 days later it finally Works
you're staring at a Red Bar most of the
time right and that is my experience of
them what happens is we go and write a
sweet tests they can't pass until we've
effectively implemented all of the code
so they're red because they're red we
don't do it until basically we want to
ship when we want to ship there's this
mad scramble to try and write these
tests afterwards they're not driving
anything
right so these tests spend all their
time red and they are hard to maintain
okay so what should you do customers
should specify acceptance criteria so
James again customers illustrate their
descriptions with concrete examples
programmers use these examples to guide
their work sometimes programmers use the
examples directly in their tests more
often programmers use examples as a
guide writing a multitude of more Focus
focused program entric tests as they use
tdd
right sometimes this is called example
driven development as well as as well um
really it's just how it how we should
have been doing tdd all along right and
that helps give us self-documenting
code all right another fallacy it
doesn't matter if you write your test
afterwards right see a lot of developers
do this they say yeah I I I do tdd but I
write the tests after because that's the
same I the same effect right um I still
under under test I know some really good
developers that say this
right okay a development process that
entails this is what test after is a
development process that entails
executing unit test after the
development of the corresponding units
is
finished
okay let's do this one implicitly what
this implies is that I have chosen to do
my design not by exploration through tdd
but by upfront design which I then
Implement and then write test to
preserve so the design decisions I have
made have not been Guided by tests and
not been Guided by Discovery through
exploration okay it's a long feedback
loop because I don't write the test
until the end so I'm getting no feedback
on the work as I go along I could go in
very much the wrong direction be faced
with a significant amount of rework tdd
is guiding you because it's saying only
the things that the except criteria
require are things that you should be
writing
not stuff and so what happens is if you
write code that's not forced by the
given requirements which is what tddd
gives you you're engaging in speculation
most likely you are wrong you find end
up doing rework at the end typically
under this kind of model rework is about
30% of the time that you spent
developing so for 10 days that's about 3
days worth of rework because you realize
this doesn't actually implement the
requirements
and often you end up with speculative
code that isn't
needed because you just say oh at some
point maybe we'll need to do this so I
add a whole L of code that does that
right so you need to do two things
right um let me just skip on that one I
think okay um you need to have design
help and you need to have scope
control tdd gives you Scope control
because it says you only write tests in
response to there being an acceptance
criteria that you need to implement so I
don't write any other code I only write
code that the customer
needs I don't speculate about future
implementation because it's almost
certain I have to rework that right and
my design evolves to be only as
complicated as I need to meet those
needs because effective my design is
informed by the test as I
go
so our principle is only write
production code in response to a test
right and only write a a test in
response to a
requirement so I basically don't write
speculative code right I have some
acceptance criteria and that's what
drives me to towards done and so I have
my my contract which I'm
exposing okay so Kent Beck again need a
way to think about design need a way to
think about scope control tdd is
basically designed by contract right
here is the contract I'm exposing to my
collaborators I don't want to write more
code than is G needed by given
requirements you want 100% test coverage
of your code this is a funny fallacy but
it is one right so um even Kent says oh
look tdd if it's followed basically
religiously should result in 100%
statement coverage right if you can't
write code unless there's basically a
requirement to drive that code and
you're not writing speculative code then
any code you write is in response to a
test and should be Behavior that's
needed by that test therefore you
shouldn't have uncovered code right if
in your code um code coverage tools help
keep you honest right it's very easy to
go oh I better have a check for if null
or whatever there right and you don't
have the actual test that conforms to
that and what you have to do is go back
sometimes and say okay I need a test
about that behavior we all we all get
into that right but in theory if you're
not writing code code unless the test
demands it then you should get 100%
coverage out the box
right
okay but I would say there are plenty of
teams out there that don't have 100%
code coverage that are doing a great job
so so where does this discrepancy come
between the two
right so this is why tdd is a tool for
use at some points in when you're doing
development but not all points tdd has
specific characteristics and does some
things very very well does other things
very badly okay so what TD gives you is
what's called Fast binary feedback
binary green or red either the test
passes or the test fa test failes binary
feedback is very easy to understand
right I made I added 10 lines of code
half my test went red there's probably a
problem in that 10 lines of code
non-binary feedback is stuff like you
know you get a whole range of rows come
out and you have to kind of manually
compare them or whatever and or you're
looking at basically a screen and trying
to go is that is that positioned right
effective Etc so that's non-binary
feedback it's quite often giving you um
information which you have to then
interpret logs for example if you if you
are nonbinary feedback
right so it turns out the binary
feedback particularly if you can get it
in like under 30 seconds is great
because it keeps guiding your
development without taking too much time
and context shifting for you out of your
head right
so don't use tdd to drive visual output
you're not exploring anything when you
try and test the user interface
basically with effectively right someone
some ux person has said make this happen
right the exploration already been done
by the ux person you are just
implementing so use exploratory testing
because these things are fragile and
very slow they're not very good for
binary testing um if you need to have
proof against regression that's when you
use classical automation right that test
after
approach similarly if you're doing
spikes or throw away
code don't use TTD that's not its
purpose right just explore the goddamn
thing use a CLI to do
it um
integration right there will be points
right as particularly if you go the tdd
route saying this needs to be fast and
and nonfragile where you may say that IO
I'm going to replace with a mock or a
stub and then I'm need to go and
Implement that so my access to the
database for example or my access to a
messaging system or whatever
right to implement that I've now got an
interface which tells me whatever what
the actual code under test needs and
I've got an SDK somewhere that tells me
how I actually Implement that you're not
exploring anything the contract already
exists right what you want to do is just
implement it so implement it debug it if
you have to follow the SDC okay and then
afterwards write some regression tests
to say I want to keep I want to keep
this working so that's a point where you
may want to use classical automated
testing right and do a test after
approach okay and don't drive third
party code right you bought third party
code to speed things up don't test drive
third party code so what this leads to
usually is what we call the testing
pyramid right some folks are down on the
testing pyramid I still am good on the
testing pyramid okay so what happens is
as you go up the pyramid your time to
feedback increases it's slower to get
the results of these tests slow means
context shifting for a developer which
is expensive the whole thing you get
someone really interrupts you for 10
minutes and you're like oh where was I
right take 20 minutes to get back we
don't want that so slow means context
shifting and basically effort means how
binary was it how much work do I have to
do to interpret the results and fr
agility how much am I getting false
posit positives where test breaks yeah
because basically we didn't have access
to that QA environment or whatever right
more fragile something is the more time
it will take us to essentially
investigate every time go oh yeah those
tests always break right we've all got
them in suet somewhere someone goes that
test is ready someone goes yeah that
always breaks don't worry about it right
um and that is a burden right because
now I don't trust results Etc so
developer
tests right have some acceptance
criteria look at the next smallest bit
of behavior I could
Implement write a failing test for that
bit of behavior get it to pass refactor
introducing lots of lovely new classes
and methods against that test I've
already got That's The Sweet Spot that's
where you want to be most of the
time some
things will not be suitable for that
testing right so where you had to
substitute IO where you need to vent to
Wi um confirmation that things are
working and all the configuration works
correctly so just basically get that
working with your debugger and then
write a classic automated test which
means you can then begin to use that
unit integration or whatever vocabulary
if you need to right to cover
that then monitoring and alerting right
your logs are really valuable sources of
information
right observability from traces is a
already valuable source of information
use
those to then test your code and then
finally at the top manual testing manual
testing is kind of dying unfortunate
there a bit of slight rant from me right
um what's happened is I mean even
Microsoft killed its software
engineering test and now we effectively
just have developers everywhere and a
number of teams that have genuine QA
practitioners is becoming vanishingly
small and it's an awful decision because
we as developers tend to basically be
people that go I will make this pass it
will succeed what you need is someone
that goes I wonder what happens if I do
this really crazy thing and you looking
at this person going why did you do that
and it breaks obviously right and the
kind of people that naturally in life
just seem to break everything around
them because they go oh I wonder what
happens if I press the button right uh
and it's a real shame that we are losing
those people but we need those a certain
number of those to actually basically do
the kind of crazy stuff that you
wouldn't just think of ever doing to the
thing right and those that's manual
testing manual testing really is still
valuable it's just you can't keep doing
it all the time right if you want a
continuous deployment model you can't
keep um doing man test if you build
something new it's okay to manually test
that explore it see what was wrong and
then effectively get that kind of
feedback before you ship to customers to
get feedback
right okay so let's
review the Comm fallacies people have
about tdd is that it's based around unit
tests right that's a concept from uh
test automation but it's not applicable
to
tdd that the trigger for a new test is a
new function before I can write a new
function I have to write a new test
right is a typical problem the idea that
essentially you're focusing tests around
functions makes them very hard to read
right very hard to understand when you
come back to them customers write
acceptance tests right it's less of a
fallacy just and more of a it just
doesn't happen
right uh but customers right acceptance
test means just give up on those tools
like SPL for Fitness right honestly
really just give up it doesn't matter if
you test first or test there are people
in the industry make they're living who
hate me right now um it doesn't matter
if you test first or test last right
there're two quite different strategies
right test first is about design or
scope control test last is about
basically regression proofing yourself
against change right they have their
point in a life cycle of doing software
development isn't the same point and you
want 100% test coverage of your code
right actually that may not be the most
effective way to get feedback on all of
your code do the most effective thing to
get feedback if you find yourself
writing a whole lot of tests and go God
it would just be easy to run it just run
it run it and then come back and figure
out how you get it under aggression
right so developers write developer or
program a test
tests right tests that essentially are
be exploring the behaviors of the system
the trigger for a new test is a new
Behavior the smallest increment you can
think to get in that behavior under
control customers write acceptance
criteria right your product owner or
someone should be telling you what
success looks like and you put that into
your developer
tests you only write production code in
response to a test right but not all of
the code should be driven by tdd so
where we want to get production code
under tdd control what we do is
effectively we use tdd to do it where we
don't think that's the right model right
my one typical most typical one is a
user interface user interfaces typically
a designer has helped us design them we
are just implementing that there is no
design by contract the contract exists
typically you just want to get that
running and then regression proof it
there's no real exploration of the user
interface what's your red green Factor
cycle look like under that model right I
Implement a failing
UI uh I then get the UI to pass and then
I refactor the UI to improve its design
doesn't make any sense right so just to
use um automated testing when you do
that all right and that's the end uh I
think that is on time so I won't invite
questions but feel free to wander up
right and and for those of you that um
you know say oh that's a really good
idea the slides are available you can
talk to your colleagues about it there
are versions of me doing this talk
online in the pandemic right it's me in
my room huddled against the you know the
impending doom uh if you need to share
with anybody but I think you might
better hopefully they'll record this so
you can share it um my other talk uh
where did it all go wrong is a bit more
of a rant if you like a rant that's more
of a rant to share with your colleagues
instead and then they can come to this
and get specific actionable advice all
right thanks very
much
for
e